je vais dire éric j'ai 60 ans moi j'ai
déjà donné dans le genre télé vedette de
télé tout ce que tu veux il ya un moment
où tu te dis il faut que je serve à
quelque chose vraiment pour laisser
quelque chose qu'on touche aux enfants
moi c'est un truc qui me j'ai des
enfants maintenant ils sont plus grands
j'espère être bientôt grand-père mais
c'est un truc qui me révulse je suis
rentré là dedans dans cette dans toutes
ces affaires de pédophilie mi na li té
par le biais mois des faits divers quand
j'ai été viré de canal je me suis
retrouvé sur une petite chaîne qui
s'appelait qui s'appelle encore 13e rue
et j'ai fait 120 documentaire ci se
passer des reportages si tu veux de 90
minutes et ses reportages je me suis axé
beaucoup sur la pédocriminalité où les
meurtres d'enfants les disparitions
d'enfants et en ayant passé beaucoup de
temps avec des avec des victimes des
proches de victimes des moments qui ont
une enfant ou un enfant disparu ça rien
à voir que deux d'être sur un plateau tu
vois comme au vrai journal thê avec des
politiques ont fui au théâtre ce soir tu
fais le mot
je vais pas dire je prend de la coke
parce que j'en prenais pas mais enfin
l'ambiance canal tu vois ce que je veux
bien de préciser c'est vrai moi c'est
pas mon rôle était à l'héroïne à
l'époque
sera bouclée mais on est en direct
finissez cap non c'est plutôt aussi
chaud mais j'ai arrêté mon prennent peu
importe non c'est pas de ma france
métissée pas le sujet s'en fout donc là
quand tu es quand tu reviens au vrai
métier de départ de journalistes où tu
prends le train tu vas voir des gens tu
es là tu comprends et tu vois tout d'un
coup devant toi une espèce de mur du
silence et tu vois comment sont traitées
ces gens par la police la gendarmerie la
justice les experts et tu découvre petit
à petit toutes ces affaires où il ya des
enfants qui sont assistées dans un
couple et on quand la mère et l'enfant
vont essayer de récupérer la garde de
l'enfant pour qu'il échappe aux papas
violeur parce que malheureusement c'est
bien souvent cas eh bien il n'y arrive
pas on va en parler tout à l'heure de sa
voix là il ya une avancée récemment on
va en parler voilà pas plus tard qu'hier
exactement va en parler mais ce que je
propose c'est de là j'ai un peu prévenu
tout le monde accueille avait des
moments un peu forcément vu le sujet
difficile dans le documentaire m'enfin
bon temps
tout le monde comprenne bien sûr les
yeux donc là c'est vraiment un des
moments les plus forts c'est une petite
fille d'entrée nom a été changé en mari
elle raconte comment son frère et elles
ont été violées par leur père et ses
amis elle parle également de meurtres
d'enfants elle dessine ce qu'elle a vécu
c'est assez terrible on regarde un
extrait de documentaire
cet endroit il y avait des grandes robes
blanches
puis il faisait des prières isoler les
enfants puis vie nous attacher aussi sur
des tables et puis ils nous frappaient
culture les enfants
comment tu veux
non mais là dans le film d'horreur là on
est dans le dans l'insoutenable je file
permettrait que j'ai vu le film de karl
zéro je crois que j'ai vu à peu près
tous ses films karl est un ami sam ou
des personnes les plus intelligentes que
je connaisse ce film est sans doute un
des plus terribles que j'ai vu de ma vie
ce film devrait être montrée pas dans
les petites classes bien sûr mais dans
les lycées peut-être dans les collèges
c'est un film extrêmement important et
si les hommes politiques pouvaient voir
ce film je pense que ça pourrait changer
dans les lois et enfin j'ai j'ai un peu
vu parce que c'est un film insoutenable
et le paradoxe est que dans l'extra
convient de voir info il faut le montrer
c'est que c'est un acte salubre que de
montrer ce film au plus de personnes
possible que faire on pourrait lancer un
appel
comment montrer le film de karl zéro
intelligemment en france 15-0 comment
comment on arrive à recueillir des
témoignages comment on procède dans
quelque chose qui dont les gens
d'ailleurs parfois n'ont pas envie de
parler c'est plus on l'a déjà évoqué sur
ce plateau il ya une culture du secret
aussi il ya cette culture du secret qui
datent pas d'hier qui date depuis des
siècles en réalité et puis il ya le fait
que en fait il ya eu il ya un an il ya
eu le livre de camille kouchner et puis
tout d'un coup la politique s'en est
emparé et on n'a en effet rien on a
vraiment espérer qu'il y aura une loi
qui protégerait les enfants et petit à
petit et c'est ce qu'on montre au
travers du film aussi été vidé cette loi
finalement c'est une loi qui est bidon
qui a été vidée de son sens à cause par
exemple de l'amendement roméo et
juliette qui autorise donc de ne pas
considérer comme des viols tout ce qui
peut se produire entre des mineurs de
moins de 15 ans et des gens qui ont
moins de 20 ans mais malheureusement 70%
des viols sur mineurs sont commis par
des gens de moins de 20 ans qui ont donc
19 18 parce que aussi
malheureusement la pornographie
maintenant est partout sur internet sur
les portables les jeunes regardent ça
ils veulent reproduire ce qu'ils voient
donc ils vont choper la petite de
l'école même si elle a 12 ans et est
donc on est dans une situation qui est
impossible qui est absolument ingérable
et donc dire on va protéger enfants mes
dires par contre ceux qui ont entre 15
et 20 ans ah non là c'est normal c'est
des dupont moratti a feint un très beau
numéro de claquettes à l'assemblée en
disant ce sont les amours adolescentes
j'entendais presque les violons mais il
s'agit pas de ça du tout c'est pas un
sujet où il faut plaisanter c'est un
sujet où il faut avancer et ils n'ont
pas avancé la loi et ya eu tellement
d'amendements que finalement c'est une
coquille vide et quand on se retrouve
face à 111,10 faut agir c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait le film se disant quand
beaucoup de monde et c'est là où c'est
important que tout le monde voie
puisqu'il est partout tout le monde doit
le voir et ensuite nous irons avec les
différentes associations voir les
candidats à la présidentielle en
proposant cinq mesures pour que ça soit
simple alors disant voilà est-ce que
vous les mettez dans votre programme
comment vous envisagé de les appliquer
si jamais vous êtes élu et bien entendu
on filmera juste pour voir leur niveau
de conscience par rapport à ça parce que
le problème est trop grave si elle me
parlait de 6 à ses moyens
c'est quoi les autres enjeux enjeu de
société que nos gosses oui comme ça vous
avez parfaitement lamelles à rien de
parler des lieux de diffusion c'est en
accès libre mais ce que vous prévoyez
d'aller les montrer alors évidemment pas
en prime un mois va envoyer en seconde
on leur donne et chacun peut le maire
mais c'est important il ya des gens qui
écoutent il veut montrer active de
montrer de manière accompagnée mais que
c'est en vérité un film comme ça il
aurait dû avoir sa place sur un service
public passé j'aime m'imposer de
présenter pourquoi c'est pas le cas mais
parce qu'ils auraient dû là là là on
touche pas on va faire des trucs feutre
et c'est ce qu'ils font depuis toujours
les derniers reportages un peu chaud là
dessus date de 2001 on est en 2021 ça
fait 20 ans que non on n'en parle plus
donc à un moment les gens il s'agit
quand même d'un sur cinq c'est 13
millions cinq cent mille personnes